y
[Música]
el presidente de ucrania volodymyr
selenski dijo que rusia inició su nueva
ofensiva militar en el este del país el
gobierno local de donges reportó que al
menos cuatro personas murieron por
bombardeos este lunes y las autoridades
de lugansk sostienen que la situación ha
empeorado desde anoche
hace exactamente cuatro años comenzaron
las movilizaciones antigubernamentales
en nicaragua los enfrentamientos con la
policía dejaron más de 350 muertos y
organizaciones como amnistía
internacional denunciaron la represión
estatal
en las presidenciales de francia
emmanuel imagine la penn se disputan los
votos de la izquierda una encuesta del
partido francia y su visa sostiene que
la mayoría de sus votantes prefieren
votar en blanco o abstenerse en vez de
respaldar a los candidatos
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión
informativa de france 24 yo soy maría
clara calle y es un placer volver a
estar con ustedes los rusos habrían
iniciado una nueva operación militar en
el este de ucrania según la presidencia
ucraniana
los ataques estarían concentrados en las
regiones separatistas de donges y
lugansk como parte de la nueva
estrategia previamente anunciada por
moscú
el gobernador de donges señaló que
cuatro personas murieron hoy por los
bombardeos y las autoridades de lugansk
confirmaron que la situación empeoró
desde anoche el mandatario volodymyr
selenski agregó que una parte
significativa de las tropas rusas se
concentran en el donbass para la
ofensiva y es que moscú está redoblando
sus fuerzas en la ciudad costera de
mariupol para garantizar un corredor
terrestre con la península de crimea y
controlar así toda la región separatista
también hubo ataques en heart kids donde
al menos dos personas murieron por
bombardeos según la fiscalía local
otro de los ataques registrados este
lunes ocurrió en el vip donde a causa de
la guerra murieron los primeros civiles
de esta ciudad del oeste y es que los
bombardeos mataron al menos a siete
personas e hirieron a otras once hay dos
versiones encontradas de cuáles fueron
los lugares atacados
maksim shatskikh el gobernador del bid
señaló que tres almacenes que no usaban
los militares y una estación de servicio
de automóviles fueron impactados por
misiles mientras que rusia asegura que
el ataque fue contra un centro de armas
que provenían del extranjero y otro
misiles lanzados desde el aire de alta
precisión de las fuerzas espaciales
rusas impactaron en el centro de apoyo
logístico conjunto 124 el comando de las
fuerzas logísticas de las tropas
ucranianas en la región del bid el
centro logístico en los grandes lotes de
armamento extranjero entregados a
ucrania en los últimos seis días por
eeuu y países europeos han sido
destruidos y esquisto los combatientes
británicos en poder de las tropas de
moscú propusieron intercambiarse por el
político opositor prorruso víctor med
del shock capturado por ucrania la
televisión estatal rusa emitió el
mensaje en el que camping y jayden slim
le pidieron al ministro británico boris
johnson que intermediaria previamente
las fuerzas ucranianas publicaron un
mensaje similar en el que me derecha les
pedía a los presidentes putin y selenski
un cambio
señor boris johnson soy john payne y han
pasado muchas cosas en las últimas cinco
o seis semanas de las que no soy
plenamente consciente
entiendo que el cinema pachuca ha sido
detenido y buscamos intercambiarlos a mí
y adina sling por él realmente
apreciaría su ayuda en este asunto e
impulsar esta genialidad cristian y
jóvenes marchan kerstin esta tienda al
menos el 30% de los edificios y de las
vías de ucrania están destruidas o
dañadas según datos del ministro de
infraestructura ucraniano oleksandr
cubra con el funcionario calculó que la
reparación podría costar hasta 100 mil
millones de dólares y propuso que la
reconstrucción del país se haga con los
activos rusos que han sido congelados
agregó que casi todos los componentes de
la infraestructura de transporte
ucraniana han sido afectados
pasamos a noticias de américa latina'
hace 4 años comenzó el estallido social
en nicaragua que dejó más de 350 muertos
en 5 meses el aniversario llegó de nuevo
bajo el liderazgo de daniel ortega quien
fue reelegido por quinta vez como
presidente en unos comicios catalogados
de antidemocráticos
me duele respirar fue el último grito de
la adolescente álvaro conrado antes de
ser asesinado por la policía
nicaragüense durante el estallido social
antigubernamental en 2018 cuatro años
después su familia reclama justicia
todavía no hay un responsable de su
muerte nosotros pedimos esta justicia
como usted ya queremos saber la verdad
de lo de los acontecimientos en ese día
álvaro fue fue uno de los primeros
heridos de muerte porque fue herido a
aproximadamente como la 11 11 y media de
la mañana guarda entonces queremos este
la verdad y justicia en 2018 miles de
nicaragüenses salieron masivamente a las
calles de todo el país en contra de una
reforma del sistema de salud propuesta
por el ejecutivo de daniel ortega
durante cinco meses nicaragua se
paralizó las autoridades sandinistas
respondieron con una brutal represión
contra los manifestantes que dejó al
menos 355 muertos cientos de detenidos y
más de 100.000 exiliados según la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos justo rodríguez un agricultor de
69 años pasó ocho meses en prisión donde
enfermo y ahora sobrevive postrado a una
cama llega el nuevo adelante pero por
qué me llevaron a ir extraer todo chapa
y me dieron en la cadena tenga un loco
el suspiro agónico del estudiante sigue
resonando en el país en noviembre de
2021 ortega fue reelegido en el cargo en
unos comicios sin garantías democráticas
y con la gran parte de la oposición en
el exilio o presos más de 100 críticos
están en la cárcel en ese momento álvaro
conrado le dolía respirar porque una
bala había atravesado su garganta en
este momento los nicaragüenses
continuamos siendo atravesado por el
dolor por el llanto por las lágrimas
por el sufrimiento
ahí hay personas que que todavía no han
podido sanar ese dolor las
organizaciones de derechos humanos
denuncian que el gobierno nicaragüenses
sigue tratando de silenciar las voces
críticas y se han prohibido las
conmemoraciones por el aniversario del
levantamiento social
ahora hablemos de las presidenciales en
francia una consulta del partido de
izquierda francia y su visa dejaban las
arrojó los resultados que muestran cómo
votarán en segunda vuelta los seguidores
del líder que se quedó en la primera
ronda detrás de manuel majo imagine
lepén el 37% de los consultados dijo que
votaría en blanco seguido de un 33% que
respaldará a mayo y el 29 por ciento
restante se abstendrá sin embargo le pen
no aparece en la encuesta pues me lanzo
sostuvo que ningún voto debería ser para
la extrema derecha otros sondeos apuntan
que una tercera parte de los votantes de
la izquierda
respaldarían al epen entretanto la nueva
encuesta de ipsos o prestaría otro g del
actual mandatario de manuel ma
convencería a la ultraconservadora lepén
con el 56% de los votos una tendencia
que se ha mantenido desde la primera
ronda del 10 de abril
a propósito de las elecciones
presidenciales francesas
la candidata ma jin le pen enfrenta un
escándalo por malversación de fondos los
fiscales de parís estudian un informe de
la agencia anti fraude de la unión
europea que acusa a la ultraconservadora
y a miembros de su partido agrupación
nacional de utilizar más de 600.000
euros de fondos públicos para beneficios
personales todo mientras ella era una
eurodiputada el informe fue divulgado
por el medio francés independiente
mediapart la cantidad a rechazó esta
investigación
a los niños estoy acostumbrada a los
juegos sucios de la unión europea unos
días antes de la segunda vuelta y creo
que los franceses no se dejan engañar en
absoluto obviamente rechazo de estas
acusaciones de las que no estaba al
tanto que ya plantean un problema en
términos de estado de derecho de lo cual
no se me proporcionó ninguna prueba
ningún elemento a pesar de las
solicitudes que pude hacer en el marco
de la campaña
en irak el bloqueo político es total
seis meses después de las elecciones
legislativas el país todavía no ha
elegido a su presidente y tampoco a su
primer ministro para ello tendrían que
reunirse dos tercios del parlamento pero
desde principios de año no se ha
alcanzado el quórum pues uno de los dos
grandes bloques políticos se niega a
compartir el poder ampliamos más en el
siguiente reportaje de nuestro equipo
que está en el terreno
en las afueras de bagdad muhannad al
azar y supervisa la construcción de
nuevas carreteras
normalmente este gestor de proyectos
dirige una docena de obras similares
pero debido al estancamiento político la
mayoría de ellos están paralizados la
mayoría era proyectos de infraestructura
como carreteras
alcantarillado electricidad etcétera se
financian con el presupuesto del estado
como aún no se ha formado el gobierno el
presupuesto no se ha presentado ni
aprobado se necesita mucho tiempo para
formar un gobierno en irak cinco meses y
medio de media el tiempo que toman las
negociaciones entre los dos bloques
políticos pero por primera vez en 20
años estas conversaciones simplemente no
se llevan a cabo porque el gran ganador
de las elecciones moqtada sádr no quiere
compartir el poder y se niega a
consultar a sus oponentes los partidos
cercanos se irán a los que pertenece
esta diputada desde 2003 la gobernanza
se basa en el consenso todos los
componentes de la sociedad deben estar
de acuerdo entre ellos ahora quieren
romper con esta tradición eso está bien
pero tenemos derecho a formar una
alianza boicotear en las sesiones
parlamentarias ninguno de estos dos
bloques políticos tiene mayoría absoluta
el resultado es que el país está ahora
en un punto muerto y la población está
sufriendo en particular en los barrios
empobrecidos donde los habitantes suelen
vivir a la espera de proyectos que
supuestamente van a mejorar sus
condiciones de vida
[Música]
durante las elecciones se nos prometió
que los proyectos se pondrían en marcha
en cuanto se formará el gobierno por
ejemplo nos dijeron que se dejarían de
todo este basural para que pudiéramos
vivir normalmente aquí si supiera esto
los enfermos que estamos por el olor y
el humo
no hay garantía de que estas promesas se
cumplan pero hasta que se forme el
gobierno la esperanza de una vida mejor
también está paralizada en el país
sudáfrica declaró estado de desastre en
todo el país por las inundaciones que
comenzaron desde la semana pasada y es
que el número de fallecidos ya supera
las
440 personas esta cifra implica que
ahora son más muertos de los que dejaron
las lluvias torrenciales de
en el país africano y que se tenían como
uno de los récords históricos cerca de
14.000 viviendas y de 40 mil personas se
han visto afectadas por los torrenciales
de este año
tras una semana de operaciones de
rescate continúa lloviendo y miranda a
las afueras de durban y decenas de
personas están desaparecidas este es uno
de los 200 trabajos de emergencia en
marcha el terreno continúa muy inestable
por lo que las autoridades pidieron la
evacuación de la zona ya no hay
posibilidades de encontrar más víctimas
con vida los perros de la policía buscan
cadáveres enterrados en el barro
los perros bajan primero para
identificar a si sabemos lo que hay que
ned con malo es un vecino de la familia
macri devastada por las inundaciones
la casa estaba aquí y se la llevó en la
tierra que se desprendió por las lluvias
la madre sobrevivió el padre murió
continuamos buscando a dos niños siguen
desaparecidos
de momento la cifra de muertos supera
las 440 personas algunos señalan la
precariedad de la infraestructura como
causa de una mortalidad tan elevada
había mucha corriente salimos y vimos
que las paredes se movían se caían los
muros colgaban y se empezó a derrumbar
la primera casa luego la segunda
los puentes se derrumbaron el agua
arrastró las carreteras aquí cayó en un
día el agua que suele precipitarse en
nueve meses este ingeniero fue testigo
de cómo la corriente se llevó los
contenedores de este barco
estaban siendo arrastrados flotando por
la autopista durante unos 78 kilómetros
la corriente los llevó por debajo del
puente
equipos de rescate de todo el país y
militares se dirigen a la zona para
ayudar a las unidades locales el
gobernador de la provincia de
kwazulu-natal hizo un llamado a la
colaboración
damos la bienvenida al apoyo de nuestras
provincias vecinas realmente apreciamos
esta asistencia humanitaria
el costo material causado por las
inundaciones todavía se está estimando
pero solo los daños en las carreteras se
calculan por encima de los 200 millones
de dólares estadounidenses una segunda
cumbre mundial sobre la pandemia de kobe
19 fue convocada para el 12 de mayo la
reunión que se llevará a cabo de manera
virtual y participará en eeuu los
miembros del g20 la comunidad del caribe
y la unión africana el evento busca
evaluar la situación actual de la crisis
sanitaria y redoblar esfuerzos para
poner fin a la fase aguda de la pandemia
por otra parte los centros para el
control y la prevención de enfermedades
de eeuu los cdc levantaron la
recomendación de no viajar a unos 90
destinos internacionales que incluye un
reino unido francia entre otras naciones
y la estrella del fútbol cristiano
ronaldo anunció que uno de sus dos hijos
gemelos falleció el futbolista y
georgina rodríguez anunciaron en octubre
que esperaban a los dos bebés y hoy el
delantero del manchester united publicó
a través de redes sociales que solo
nació la niña el agradeció la atención
clínica y pidió respeto a su familia
durante esta pérdida
y nos despedimos con una invitación y es
que a partir de hoy inicia en france24
directo a américa edición nocturna este
programa estará de lunes a viernes a las
19 horas en bogotá quito lima santiago
lópez y valentina torre sánchez estarán
con ustedes para dos horas de
información con las noticias el debate y
las actualizaciones de los deportes y la
economía
sigan con nosotros
[Música]